I don't know about you but I'm Kate
McKinnon and I'm Vanessa Bayer and we're
doing the autocomplete interview yes
this Kate McKinnon nice gosh I hope so
I try really hard I honestly try really
hard
related am I related to Jeremy McKinnon
not familiar with him no not a cousin of
mine it's Kate McKinnon on snapchat no
she's not or on Twitter or Instagram
Kate McKinnon Russian just an accent I
like to do I have a cat who I like to
imagine is Russian Kate we can
Australian gosh I wish but no just
another accent I like to do I'm boring
who is Vanessa bear I'm still trying to
find that out
cartwheel all right who they are related
to oh my brother Jonah and his last name
is Jonah
I mean his last name's beggar his name
is Jonah bear and he's a renowned music
journalist how much is the Nessa bear
Worth's the world I'll answer that for
you the whole universe more than you can
afford Vanessa Bayer from she's from
Cleveland
that's an Ohio how old is Vanessa bear
more than you can afford
let's okay you want answer for me yeah
okay let's see if you know the answers
this case we've already answered this no
she does not
just Kate McKinnon sing like an angel I
don't she also plays piano just keep
making in facebook you better not
believe it yeah do it she doesn't do
social medias like Hillary baby
Hilary Justin Bieber impression no that
room nicely there so you don't get an
answer
you're in service for free yeah okay
okay Vanessa Bayer has just joined
Twitter and she's very into it I joined
like two years ago but ing joins does
Vanessa Bayer in scream yes you do
okay does Vanessa Bayer Yahoo I'm gonna
say no okay look I think if your person
alive today you're emailing and Vanessa
Bayer is one of them Vanessa Bayer does
Miley Cyrus yes she does better than
anyone in this world
Wow what an angel you are Kate McKinnon
looks like Elizabeth Banks I'll take it
Long Island
what problem where she's from I'm on it
where sure I'd do an impression of her
and I love her dancing I do it I love it
what about you I do it she's got a ton
huh
she's been there on a train OMI I feel
like there's an Adam and Eve commercial
maybe that people think I'm in but I'm
not it's not me false false claim balls
the internet failed us identify did you
do a she end up at that College that's
fun you know if you want to chase Enel
she doesn't incredible incredible again
did they do Jennifer Aniston impression
think of our generation and last
I really do know each other yeah we've
always been like sisters so NASA right
thank you for your support thank you
we'll be here
don't be
[Music]